Where on the website are the instructions for the easy peasy coffee edema? Well, let's look right now.
Alright.
Sorry.
So it's on the detoxification details page. So on the member site, so on the website.
So go to the member site that's on the detoxification details site.
It's in also several of the courses. It's in this definitely in the seven basic detox course.
Multiple pages, but on the member site, it's on the page that says detoxification details.
And where is the information about the auto view Syrex panel. So Syrex is spelled with a C Syrex panel that it's called array 10.
That is there's tons of information about that on the auto view course.
There's really got a lot of information on that. If any of the members site.
But on the auto view course, there's a ton of information on that. And you can get that.
If you click on the member site, you click on the labs and go to our lab portal with group of health, then you can order that array 10 panel.
So if you want information, I actually created numerous videos on why you test for foods and and everything on the auto view course.